the Joe Rogan experience people believe
weird [ __ ] they definitely like like the
people that really want to believe in
Bigfoot or the people that really want
to believe in UFOs like UFOs are coming
back right now everybody's talking ever
bigger than stronger than ever that
should tell you something
Dave Foley's hooked Dave Foley from News
Radio remember Dave Howard cooked we
text each other almost exclusively about
UFO evidence I know I was the big misis
a New York Times a couple days ago oh
wow what is that Navy pilots report
unidentified flying objects here's the
thing though we don't know what kind of
[ __ ] the Chinese have figured out we
don't know what kind of [ __ ] the
Russians who figured out we assume that
we know because but we did we didn't let
them know about the stealth bomber or
any of the crazy [ __ ] that they were
building in area 51 we didn't let them
know do you know me I was balls deep
into the you know community might at the
first tattoo I got I got an alien on my
left arm in a Jovian garb I was always
into [ __ ] ancient Egypt the
conspiracy side of the ancient Egypt
there's the mainstream Egyptology I was
into the though oh look what Graham
Hancock is saying and UFOs mmm there's
so much proof in my head there was so
much proof that the government was
trying to cover up look the why are they
covering it up why are they covering it
up look at all these guys from pilots
from the Air Force are saying they saw
UFOs pilots from the Navy are saying
they saw UFOs dudes from the Pentagon
it's gotta be true that's a dude that's
a dude that's a CIA pilot he's saying it
so when you're when your balls deep and
you really want to believe it you look
at it that way like look there's all
these government officials saying they
saw UFOs and they got their own UFO
story you know and then um you know you
listen to Bill Cooper and he was former
office of naval intelligence officer and
you know and and when you hear what he
says he wrote that book behold the pale
white horse he was that guy said crazy
[ __ ] he said there's a base on the moon
not that guy that's not behold the pale
white horse he said there's a base on
the ass
yes no he at first didn't mean at four
now you're talking about no leader
you're talking about oh no that guy's
crazy too right holy what does that guy
say he says that um there's millions of
people on each planet and they're all
every planet has millions of people is
he the guy that owns skinwalker ranch I
don't know but he was a part of his dad
owned Learjet right right I forget what
that there's Nana seems like a super
rich troll totally when he says what he
says the crazy [ __ ] he says I'm like
this guy's having a good time [ __ ]
with people yeah totally but Bill Cooper
says that because his job was to prepare
notes top secret notes classified [ __ ]
it for meetings with high-level people
in the military and he was based on what
he was reading was like damn UFOs are
real look I have proof so that at first
he was like for sure UFOs are real for
sure they're hiding that's what he was
saying he was preaching that then he
learned later they let him whistle blow
he never got busted for whistle blown
that they were they want him they wanted
him to leak that UFO that's what his
conclusion was he started to realize
wait a minute they want me to leak this
and then he he got to the point where he
believes that all UFO abductions like oh
like the he believes that um everything
was a product of the government all UFO
sightings abductions they're taking you
and it's he believes it's like the CIA
doing that [ __ ] and he was that's what
he was really about before he got
murdered man they went up to us ranch
and [ __ ] them up if they wanted to
really [ __ ] with you this is what I
think they would do they would first of
all that would put acid on your [ __ ]
they put acid on your doorknob or
something like that because there was a
dude who found something I forget what
he found some old thing and as he was
opening it up he he act just by touching
it it was like some old thing it was
dipped in acid and he went on an acid
trip for like six hours so this would
they do they dose you up they'd somehow
or another dose you up whether touching
a doorknob just finally guy
it's unreal a recent story it's a guy
that was cleaning a board like this a
sound board that's it what it was he
touched that's what it was it's like uh
telling us go for anything I think I'm
[ __ ] high yes and they did ended up
testing and that's exactly the story
that's exactly the story so they could
do that to you and then sneak up on you
with some special effects where some
[ __ ] crazy mask and [ __ ] flash you
with lights and you're so crazy high you
don't know what the [ __ ] going on they
grab you and put you want to tell a desk
and tell you you you've been abducted by
aliens from another planet you don't
think they [ __ ] with people did
something like that do for you see the
documentary abducted in plain sight no I
have not which ones you do it's not
about exactly it's not about UFOs and
well it's a bit sort of sort of this guy
he was married had a couple kids he was
tight with the family who had three
daughters he was a predator so he
targeted he targeted the twelve-year-old
and what he did is he had sudden like
[ __ ] with the mom [ __ ] with the dad
[ __ ] the dad in sex with the dead
sexual relations and some of the dad not
[ __ ] Adam did dad jerked him off oh
they talk about this on the bus the guy
just jerked him off the guy jerked him
off he got out he convinced the guy to
jerk him off so he wanted blackmail on
the parents right so that once he took
the daughter they couldn't say [ __ ] cuz
I black now because he jerked them off
and he [ __ ] with the mother too and it
was it was a secret so of course that
guy doesn't want none of that [ __ ] so
let's say I take his kid he's gonna T he
has to take the daughter uh horseback
riding so and they were like okay so he
takes the daughter horseback riding and
what he does is he starts telling her
that there's all these alien abductions
going on and we got to be careful for
aliens she's 12 years old so he's
setting her up so when he does he drugs
her she wakes up she strapped to a table
he's got a speaker with alien voices
coming out and the alien and she wakes
up she didn't know where she's at like
oh my god and this this alien voice says
that she is responsible for saving the
earth she has to marry that dude she has
to marry the dude in the alien voice you
have to marry Bob and you have to have
this but you can't tell nobody
and then
I don't know and then she passes out
again and she wakes up and she's not
strapped she's looking around the
trailer and she sees the guy he's about
he's pretending he's all [ __ ] up and
she's like waking him up and he's like
that's fake blood on him or whatever and
then he wakes up and then she tells him
we've been abducted by aliens and I need
to have your child
oh he tricked her so from the age of 12
to 16 he owned her did the they ended up
catching him with the girl like a week
later FBI gets involved and the girl
can't tell anybody or everyone ties so
so she's obsessed now she's back with
the family the guys in jail for like a
day cuz well you know what he does is he
has his lawyers send letters to the
mother and father saying to make him
sign like that it was consensual what he
threatened the blackmail so they signed
it and let him out they signed and they
let him out and then he goes dead like
the next state over but that chick she's
a good she's 12 13 14 and she's obsessed
with him she has to save the world so
that that's an example of and then it
turns out it turns out that he I think
the guy was CIA probably and he knew
that he knew those techniques that's how
they get people they fill him up say
there's all these alien invent
abductions get them all scared and then
boom when they do it they believe it
Jesus Christ yeah so that's just MKULTRA
[ __ ] did she got him Caltrain I
guarantee they did that to people who
are like political enemies [ __ ] you
why wouldn't they do that it's easy huh
it's ease it just seems like something
they would do to just seems like it
makes sense and then bill Cooper said
that the mutilated terrible thing that
people were saying oh you bought those
are taking them because they're you know
they're the organs were taken out so
surgically that we don't have the key
that uh about what bill Cooper he was he
got balls deep into that he started
getting into breaking down what's really
happening with UFOs he's gone oh [ __ ]
we're being played where the government
is pretending to cover it up there they
want to push it they want people to
believe in aliens so what do you think
that the counter mutilations were you
think there were tests and weapons on
these cattle the bill Cooper said it was
really simple all the cattle were found
by military bases and what they do is
they
when they're constantly check checking
radiation levels around bases constantly
so what they do is if there's cows
they'll routinely take a cow take out
its rectum take out it like certain
organs surgically and then they dump
them just to scare people just let them
it'll kill two birds with one stone they
really needed to get some radiation but
it's always good it's always good to
push UFOs it's always good to scare
people with aliens I wonder if those
those cattle abductions if they
coincided with areas where there was
like some sort of toxic dump you know
there's some big ammunition dump or
something like that like anything where
some corner but do they have more of
them around Nevada where they did all
those nuclear tests I'm not sure but the
gist of what Bill Cooper said was found
near military bases and he knows like
once he looked into it it's like oh I
know what they're doing they're checking
radiation levels and they're scaring
people at the same time mmm that makes
sense because it was surgically removed
right like people can do that like why
would that eliminate the possibility
that people could do it of course people
could do it but you know people like the
only aliens could do that and then they
take it and then they move it to another
place so that the blood is not in the
spot where they find the animal that's
all it is did I'm a crazy that's how
they catch poachers you know do you know
that how they catch poachers that way
sometimes they find out where the gut
pile is so I say if you you didn't
really have a tag to shoot a deer and
then you shot a deer in another place
where you're not supposed to be but you
have a tag at a different place you you
just you because if there's some places
where it's easier to get tags you just
take the deer out of the forbidden place
take a picture of it or some like that
and then go back home
well they busted people because they
like Park Rangers recognized certain
mountain peaks and they ignore no you
weren't there I know exactly what you
were when you when you killed this deer
you were in a different place and then
they go to that different place and they
cope they look at the fake the picture
and they try to coordinate and then they
find the gut pile and then they convict
people of poaching hmm that's happened
before hmm look at the photos yeah yeah
so like so that's what makes sense that
they would do that they would do it
because then when you if you think you
took that animal and killed it and cut
it and left this big bloody pot and then
put it in a truck and then
dragged it 10 miles away and dropped it
off there people like this is crazy
there's no blood at the scene of the
crime all the Bloods missing it's been
surgically removed like no one can do
this
this is impossible aliens literally no
blood on the ground
yeah because they put a day you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] wit you think aliens came this far
to [ __ ] with cows imagine if we went all
the way up to like Neptune that should
go first
[ __ ] up your Gophers jáchym cut their
dicks off throw them back it's funny man
that's exactly what they thought aliens
did and it's hilarious cattle
mutilations are [ __ ] hilarious in
that regard
yeah no it's gross too though that they
did it so many times that it became a
thing that people looked for and then
they let all these people who believe in
aliens anyway
they let all these people just students
they're trying to scare us they're
trying to scare us with aliens for sure
[Applause]